Hey, Vsauce. Michael here,
coming from Kansas for the 4th of July.
Why Kansas? Well, because out here you can
do anything. You can even put a firework
store
next to a gas station. But enough about
the real world, let's talk about DONGs,
things you can do online now guys.
If your style is minimalist, play Nathan's
recommendation,
the Level Game. It's really simple,
but gets increasingly reliant on
you being clever. This Wesaucer
asked if there's a way to detect whether
an image has been
Photoshopped. One of my favorites is
Error Level Analysis.com
This site will automatically convert
your image to a known quality
and then compare. The higher the quality
the jpeg the better.
Here's a picture of Bruce Willis's
daughter with a Photoshopped version on
the right.
Notice all the activity around her face
and chin. Gotcha,
a fake. I've been playing a lot of iRunner
lately but for a similar
browser-based running game,
"Adamdre" says 'Kawairun.'
Jump, slide,
survive. "FraserGodfrey" pointed me to a
great site where you can choose fun
ASCII fonts and then it will turn whatever you
type into neat ASCII
art you can copy and paste into e-mails,
websites, forums, wherever.
The very same site has a typing test,
which I know sounds kinda lame,
but you can practice your speed and
after the test see a heat map
of which letters you type the fastest and
which ones are your weakest.
If you want some music,
check out 'Undo' from The Half Pennies.
Wait for it. Vsauce. There are some other
references to YouTubers hidden
throughout
and if you have time, try to find them all.
If you're sick of flat music videos,
"MegaUltranerd" told me about
this music video, where you can use your
cursor to click and drag your
perspective around
to see other parts of the scene.
But now let's get psychic with
"Linkfirexs." 'Akinator' is classic,
but he still blows my mind.
Think of a character and
actor, singer, scientist, cartoon
superhero,
whoever.
Answer his simple questions and watch his
eerie brilliance shine through.
If you never leave the house, you might like
Bars of black-and-white,
an awesome point-and-click about a sad
guy who receives a barcode scanner
that can scan some things you wouldn't expect.
Or
stay indoors and inside your games with
'Candy Catch,'
a neat little webcam-based game where you navigate
your body through reversed and flipped
images to grab the candy and not
the dangerous pumpkins. Alright, that
does it for games, but on Saturday I went
down to Joplin, Missouri
to help out.
It's been more than a month since the tornado hit
and this is how things look now.
The preciseness of the storm
is so chilling. On one side of the street
houses are together
and on the other they're not.
But of course, there are DONGs you can do about
it.
You can donate and you can also learn
about tornadoes and tornado safety.
Stay safe this 4th of July.
And as always,
thanks for watching.